[Music]
all right here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
so Gotham has ended and I stopped doing
up so by episode reviews of season 5
that was as it was airing partly just
because I was having trouble fitting it
in my schedule but also I started
finding I wasn't enjoying season 5 very
much and ultimately I don't like season
5 and that that really frustrates me
because I love Gotham Gotham has been
one of my favorite shows on television
for the last few years
I love the insanity of it I love how
campy it is while at the same time being
dark it's it's a wonderful blend of
elements and I love it but this season
okay so it wasn't a complete and utter
faceplant and this is probably one of
the few times because I people will
accuse me of this and I actually don't
think I'd do it very often because well
I'll explain why in a second so it's not
uncommon for me when I complain about
movies TV shows what have you that
people accused me of it just not being
what I wanted to be in that like well
you must have had a specific idea in
your mind you're just mad there wasn't
that which I don't think happens to me
very often at all because the thing is
if you follow me for long enough you
would know that like in the live streams
or whatnot people like oh what do you
think they should do with this story or
this property and my answer is always
like
I don't know like I don't come up in my
mind with what I think these things
should do I don't that's just not really
something I do my brain doesn't work
that way this is about the one time I
will kind of cop to that being a factor
though that the way they chose to end
this is not what I wanted and I had a
more specific idea of what I wanted but
I'm still not gonna give the show a pass
for that because I feel like what I
wanted was really reasonable and would
have made a heck of a lot more sense
than what they did so I'll get into that
a bit more as we go ok look overall it's
it's it's not like the last season of
Dexter alright it by no means ruins the
show it doesn't make it so like god I
can't even watch the good seasons
anymore that's how bad is it it's
nothing like that I just found this to
be a big disappointment and I feel like
if I were to try and pinpoint the
problem I feel like they didn't do
enough with the fact that this was the
last season and what I mean by that is
they knew going in because it wasn't
long after season four aired it was
right when the renewal for Gotham came
down they were told okay last season
short season and I feel like what they
did was rather than go oh okay if this
is the last season we got a really do
whatever we were planning long term
might set that aside let's really blow
this out I feel like what they did
instead was take whatever had been their
plan for a full season of Gotham
presuming that it wasn't going to be the
last condense that down to 12 episodes
or really 11 episodes out of code at the
end but not restructured in a way so
that it feels like a proper payoff first
off and that's that's my big issue with
season 5 I'll have more specific issues
as I go along I'm sure but the big core
one for me is I given that the set up at
the end of season 4 when they set up for
no-man's land
what makes no man's land great as a
story and why I was so excited to see it
in Gotham was that the whole idea of
no-man's land is the elements that are
already in Gotham just at each other's
throats no-holds-barred they have no
reason to hold back anymore and it's
just dirty fighting you know between all
these factions but there are the
factions of the people who are already
there so that so much of the plot
especially in the second half of the
season hinges on an outside force and
new villains who I don't like but I'll
come back to them that is really
infuriating for me because this show had
everything it needed to go nuts in its
last season everything was already in
place all the characters that they
already had they didn't need a new
outside force coming in heck there were
villains that are still around that we
didn't even see like early on there's a
reference that like Mr Freeze and
Firefly our war with each other and we
never see them I would much rather have
seen that than this stupid friggin Bane
and the okay I said I'm gonna deal with
that later on I will deal with that
later but like and mr. freeze a fire
fire aren't even like particular
favorites of mine but it's like you had
everything you had all the material you
had more than enough material to fill 12
seasons and pay off and just dwell in
and give us celebration of the
characters we already had and the
characters that we already loved as fans
and you didn't I don't know why not and
I think in some ways the whole thing
that was done with Jeremiah having him
replaced Jerome
filled now in hindsight feels like that
was a warning sign for how season 5
wasn't gonna quite pull together because
in and of himself there's really not
that much wrong with Jeremiah he's a
perfectly valid interpretation of the
Joker but you don't need him
we had Jerome there were there's nothing
really that I feel was substantively
gained by taking Jerome off the board
giving us Jeremiah who felt you was for
a while a very different character but
then by the end and especially in the
little coda thing was basically just
acting like Jerome again why didn't you
just let us keep Jerome like what why
why couldn't you keep using the thing
that we were already invested in okay so
what's good well most of the characters
that I love are still good although some
of them how stupid things happen to them
again I'll mention it as I go
Gordon's good he's solid Bullock's good
Victor Victor Zsasz he's not in this
season much but Oh done I love it when
he was oh it made me so happy just is
his casualness with all of this stuff
when he's a buddy and he's about to get
his head chopped off or he's just taking
potshots at Jim Gordon just hey guys how
you doing I loved him so much he was
great penguin was good penguins always
good seeing penguin and Ed together
again that was great
even though it was rushed I can't
like the thing they did to have the
tabla ventriloquist
I did kind of like that again it was
rushed it felt like in the in their
original plan for season five when they
thought they might have had a full
season that maybe he was supposed to be
a two or three Episode story and they
crammed him into one but its own I liked
him I mean I like the I like the
ventriloquist anyway I think he's one of
the more underrated Batman Mills to be
completely honest but I liked him he was
solid
[Music]
did I mention Barbara already Barbara
Barbara was good I have mixed feelings
up okay I should have said at the front
end spoilers like yes just spoilers I've
kind of just gone bits and pieces up to
now but like I'm getting it the flat out
spoilers at this point so not a huge fan
of season five other people might liked
it more I'm jealous of them that they
liked it I wished I could have but so
Barbara I have mixed feelings about her
basically seeming to go straight and go
normal for lack of a better word you
know would that with the finale you know
because it has the 10-year flash-forward
I've mixed feelings about that because
on the one there on the one hand like I
like her being Barbara and and it feels
in some ways like uh like a kneecapping
of the character but then again on the
other hand I can speak from personal
experience and say that in some ways
having a kid mellows you out so I don't
know I don't love it but I don't hate it
we'll go with that um Bruce was Bruce
was good actually that that actor really
grew on me by the time he was done Lee
was pretty good I liked Lee last season
best though and try thank God who else I
mean you know Lucius Fox was good Alfred
was good
we got Hugh estranged back briefly but
that was always nice huh Selina Selina
was fine but the things I the thing I
didn't like from earlier in the season
proved to be completely flipping
pointless so they had this whole thing
or Selina couldn't walk and Bruce finds
I the the less interesting version of
ivy and gets like this natural plant
thing to help Selina and his Warren like
it's going to change who she is he gives
it to her and now she can walk again and
like they did like a weird tease like
she had freaky cat eyes and like this
implication that was gonna make her go
crazy or go like super dark or something
but she just kind of doesn't and like
you like I don't get what the point of
any of that was because where Selina is
by the end of the show both within the
arc of the primary part of the season
and in the ten-year flash-forward is all
places I could believe her just ending
up based off how the character was she
doesn't end up at such an extreme that
it makes any sense to have a narrative
like oh she was pushed into a more
extreme version by this seed or whatever
the hell it was like well no this is
totally in line with who she was and the
trajectory of where she was going as a
character why did you insert this Oh
darkness seed when she doesn't even go
that frigging dark not not compared to
how she was already going like her hunt
if the idea was like her hunting down
Jeremiah for revenge like I believe she
would have done that anyways like what
the hell what was the point
echo was fine as sort of the the proto
Harley Quinn I mean I kind of wish
that they've gotta found a way to bring
Lori petti back from my what is probably
still my favorite episode of the entire
show that ball this ball of mud mean
this from season two because I like her
a little bit better as kind of a Harley
Quinn desk but you know echo was fine
but okay I've got kind of been dancing
around a little bit but the thing that
really just infuriated me for this for
this season so the main villain thing
they bring in Eduardo who ends up being
Bane which a young we didn't need we
have more than enough villains in Gotham
we did not need Bane but even if they
were gonna do that even if they were
gonna have some version of Bane why did
they lift so much from the Dark Knight
Rises
which isn't even that well regarded at
this point like why did you lift the
style of voice
the look for the mask of Bane the fact
that he is serving as another villain
and that villain turns out to be Ra's al
Ghul's secret daughter that nobody knew
about oh but it's totally different from
the Dark Knight Rises
cuz it's Nyssa al Ghul the half-sister
to tell you that nobody friggin
remembers like what why what the one
thing the one thing that Gotham through
all the subs and downs has not been has
been derivative and I know that sounds
weird cuz it's an adaptation of an
existing thing so it's like it's pulling
all this stuff
yeah but it was always doing its own
thing with it Gotham never felt like it
was doing some previous version of
Batman that was part of what I loved
about it
so it's part of why a lot of Batman fans
bailed on it almost immediately
cuz it didn't line up with any version
of Gotham and Batman and these
characters that they knew but once I got
my head wrapped around that I love that
but I'm sitting here watching this going
I saw the Dark Knight Rises I didn't
really like the Dark Knight Rises why am
I seeing it again why ah I am genuinely
actually way more frustrated about this
than I even thought I was gonna be you
and I sat down to start recording this
I'm just so infuriated you had a perfect
setup a perfect setup to just have this
insane cast go at each other's throats
in utter chaos for 12 episodes and I
would have loved it
you had that go on for like maybe three
or four episodes at the front end and
then decide to bring in the military and
Bane and Nyssa al Ghul who was a
character I cannot possibly care about
because we never met her before she's
bland as hell like Gia
anything anything with the character we
already knew heck bring people back from
the dead you've done it plenty of times
like bring back bring Sophia Falcone
back that I would have bought that way
better than Nyssa al Ghul who who was
sitting here going oh I sure hope they
they rip off the Dark Knight Rises and
then have Ra's al Ghul's kid come in
I'll be disappointed if that's who are
these fans that said that I don't know
who they are they aren't me
I'm really really irritated I'm a little
bit irritated with myself for getting
this upset I don't want to be this upset
because again this is this is the time
that I will concede I had a pretty clear
idea in my head not like specific story
B's but I had a general projection of
what I thought the season was
to be what I thought they setup which
was why I let myself get excited for
that idea because I'm like well this is
obviously what they've set up so I'll
sit down and watch this but not only was
it not that well it is I don't I also
don't think it's very good even on its
own terms there are bits there are
moments even some of the stuff I
complained about like I complained about
Jeremiah Jeremiah is fine
Jeremiah works I still like Jerome
better given that I liked your own
better I don't see why we had to do this
and replace him but Jeremiah is fine
most of the returning cast is fine even
though some stupid things were done with
some of the characters at some points
but the show just it it had such a
perfect setup to close out why they did
the story that they did I will never
know and as for the finale I call it a
finale I think of it more as a coda
which is kind of an ending note a little
bit of the flash forward which was she
was fine it's kind of nice it was it was
kind of cool to see some of the
characters and the more sort of
traditional comic cookie costumes like
it's like with the penguin like with
Jeremiah being the Joker even though
they still can't say it whatever
seeing Jim with the bust taps video'd
shaves off like I try to think it didn't
work no it didn't and I and like I kind
of oddly like the the weird three people
raising a kid thing between Barbara Lee
and Jim so like there are things that
are good there are things that work but
for something that I for a show that I
love as much as I loved Gotham for I
would say seasons 2/3 and most of for I
loved this show I don't love this last
season I'm not even sure
and the things that I don't like about
it infuriate me that's Gotham season
five
we'll get into better moods though
because now that it's over I'm gonna
have Liz back on and we're gonna do a
top ten favorite characters from Gotham
like we did with her Buffy so yeah
that's look forward to but Gotham it's
over what did you think about it did you
like it better than I did
I imagine that can't be too hard
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff to do
because there's buttons and links and my
book and all sorts of stuff it's all
down below click on it it'll take you
places but you also don't have to if you
don't want to because at the end of the
day you're the council I just run the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]